foreign
oh
my God
foreign
oh we live Shawty relax Shawty
what what what we live shouting
Moody Verma he says what up Moody
environment
comment
what's goody Moody what's goody everyone
what's goody what's goody
welcome
hour
yes and I am recovered I'm a recovered
TCU Horned frog it was a rough weekend
it was a rough day we are back
the skies are not looking as gray as
they did
on that night
my boy
we are chat
I got yeah I guess you hadn't we hadn't
done one of these since
if you want to call it a game
we can call it a scrimmage
we just
show up and
um
yeah we showed up but I think we forgot
to watch the tape
we just you know something let's just
play let's just go play football and
what we didn't realize is uh Georgia was
not playing football
Georgia was playing
grow man
uh
just assassination it was like like I
don't know if you
imagine an entire crowd half of a crowd
just finding out that their dog died
after a quarterback
after like
eight minutes into the game you get a
text message your dog just died
that's how that TCU game felt
for the rest of the 40 minutes after
that you're like okay we're just not
going to be in a good mood and Nothing's
Gonna Change that's pretty much what it
was and then you get another text
message every time that they scored
about how traffic the death was
just they just keep adding facts like
nope he got ran over actually he got hit
by two cars and then a vulture came and
then ripped his heart and then
something else came and then ran over
the dog once more it was that level of
just gut-wrenching Agony to just watch I
was like
yeah and you you got what's funny is
it was a dog killing the dog so it was
the dogs that killed the toads the
horned frog yes it was what was it what
was it like to see it live like what was
the mood in the stadium
it was absolutely gut-wrenching
[Laughter]
just the souls got snatched out you ever
see like it was like Mortal Kombat like
get over here and just ripped it out it
was every fighting game we got oh you
can we got like every every fighting
analogy you can think of that's why
it was bad hey I gotta take this call
real quick no you're good I'm trying to
get my camera right anyway yeah you're
good
foreign
[Laughter]
how he just rolled out a screen he was
just like
that was hilarious
oh boy all right we we deep in here
though what's goody everyone I'm trying
to get
y'all see this like it's like a glare
happening I'm trying to figure out
because it's really
and it happens when I lean
oh what if I just turn
oh
how about now
if I just turn okay oh it went away cool
maybe we should turn down the light
behind me
turn that down a little bit ooh
[Music]
I feel like I'm a lot of focus I focused
it
how about that that's not terrible
there we go I don't hate that right
there y'all can see I got a new plant
right there
right there right there right there
right there it's a money plant
because my fiddle leaf fig decided to
die
but we are alive and well thank you all
for hanging out oh my gosh we appreciate
y'all for coming out
without any
promotion we don't promote this at all
and y'all still come out and we really
appreciate that
so
we see the plan thank you dark alley
I appreciate that but then over here
trying to go solo dolo
but we got we've deep in here today we
got moved deep we got Eric
we love shouty big facts Tracy J
hosted my first open mic last night
congratulations there Tracy J
how'd it go
dark alley says
last night's open like rough hilarious
it happens
it'd be like that sometimes
Bobby said hello everybody
I'm up and walking on my own again
congratulations they wanted to put me on
a respirator but I told them no way I've
got to post the hot breath word of the
day
that's so Bobby
[Laughter]
oh we love that
thank you Bobby
and Jerry Crowell in here keto Carol
said she missed us last week
yay so we're the best part of Tuesdays
oh my gosh
I love it the fact that people show up
and we never promote this in the least
bit
the fact that they show up not even
knowing if it's gonna happen
not even knowing if there's going to be
a last minute post that's like ah never
mind
yeah yeah we really appreciate that well
that doesn't happen often I mean I feel
like we've only had like three
cancellations all year
right yeah yeah you know we're only a
few weeks into the year but you know
there are there are there's still time
no less it's like week three oh of last
year I was like it's like week three of
the New Year we're like we've only
canceled like three times guys this
whole year
laughs
but exactly
Lance in the building John mon dragon
oh yeah hello
[Music]
so this is the joke feedback hour so
welcome feel free to post your jokes for
feedback
this music is
there we go we're officially here what's
goody
let me get in Focus there
there we go
you in you in Focus baby
we in Focus Shawty
oh and Tracy J had hosted her first open
mic last night and she said it went
great there were 12 comedians
hey that's it right there
gang gang
gang gang congratulations
we're doing the Lord's work when you
open a when you host an open mic
that's that is that is God talking to
you just go hard
I moved to one for seven years
make sure that the words that come out
of these comedians mouths within this
five minutes at least four things are
funny at least maybe three God if you
can make one thing funny that would be
absolutely Grand no it's horrendous
it's horrendous out there in these
streets
this opened my life
bruh
it's it's rough out there
it's rough out there kiddos
oh but Joan in here Jones says hi all
hello and Aaron Aldridge
says no open mic in Athens went great oh
new open mic in Athens went great last
night
at I heart mac and cheese ooh
very nice
good looking outside
do you host that open mic app
yeah out there in Athens
Phil said he's expecting a granddaughter
but what oh is it a joke oh maybe I
think he's I think it's a joke
posting a joke for joke feedback he
posted on our Facebook group
[Music]
um
and it said expecting a granddaughter
last November but kovid with covet all
the deliveries from China have been
unpredictable
explain that
you don't mind that one
yeah like I think
I think it's it's one of those things
that you know
hopefully it's true because it has
context and I'm learning a lot about you
uh
but you know I think yeah I like the
punchline that all the things from China
are predictable like that's a very
business
level joke like a lot of people who
watch Bloomberg may get that because
they understand supply chain yeah
right so I enjoyed it I don't know if
people would get it at open mic to be
honest with you because I'm not sure
people are not people let me take that
back I'm not sure if the world is that
in tune with those kind of problems to
know that that's
a thing I think the covet China
definitely but the delivery is an
unpredictability I'm not sure supply
chain has made it to where everyone
knows that that's an issue and just what
takes me out of it is is his
granddaughter coming from China like I
don't I don't quite see where the
connection is there
you know what I mean
if he's expecting a granddaughter but oh
yeah I don't know it doesn't really
yeah it doesn't really correlate there
for me so maybe if it was like he was
maybe adopting and that may
connect a little bit more to like
adopting a kid from China but um
yeah yeah I get that yeah yeah that
wasn't I think I just assumed
that it was from China right or Chinese
like so that's why I made that
assumption but it's a good point like if
you didn't get it or you didn't make the
connection it was gonna be you know
people that don't get that as well
yeah but um I mean overall I I get the
joke
I see it yeah
that's cool
well thank you first joke out Phil
[Applause]
foreign
I hope that's correct ketron
I hope it's probably that's why I hope
but if Phil uh Phil helped me book a
headlining weekend in Bristol
yeah
okay what
I said you still didn't know how to
pronounce his name
that's right
I got it I got you Phil don't let Yoshi
you know you know it was MLK day
yesterday you know he's trying to he's
trying to drive a rift between us you
know don't let it happen I believe one
day on a little Joe babies
I'm sure you saw the new Statue
which statue you know King
oh
oh I've got to show you and you've got
to watch it I want everyone to see this
I'll pull it up on screen you've got to
watch Kev on stage
talk about it
is
so funny
it is so funny
I heard somebody mention it
and yeah
yeah that's ridiculous
let me see if um we can bring it up here
oh let me get Yoshi in here hold on
there we go all right let me see if um
this will be worth it everyone
let me get it centered here
it's so funny he's so funny
this is perfect a white guy bringing
this up
all right we'll start it over
we don't take nothing seriously
listen there's a problem with me I I
can't blame the artist because I read
the tweet this is supposed to honor
Martin Luther King and Coretta Scott
King but my mind don't see that and I
don't even want to say what my mind sees
because I'm embarrassed that knowing
what I know I see something else from
this angle
I don't I don't I see an Embrace but
it's a different kind of embrace it's an
Embrace I know well I enjoy but it ain't
what I know that's what not the sculptor
said I know the Potter don't want that a
guy who's he put that up he didn't see
that but this angle I do and I'm ashamed
from this angle
I don't even know what that supposed to
be because it looked like something else
okay so somebody hit me the game they
they showed me the picture I said well
y'all got to put the picture next to it
because without the picture it do look
like what I thought y'all got to light
it up and show the buttons because
otherwise
there's a problem with me
it's so good
that's really funny it's so funny I
think you're supposed to be an embrace
um yeah and that is uh
uh just and I think here's the thing the
artist probably only saw it from one
angle when they did it
and did not move like they didn't move
around when they were building they were
just building that thing just straight
on
no dude I feel bad I feel bad for the
artist because it's like they poured
their heart and soul into this and
they're like this is an opportunity for
me to really celebrate this historical
figure and then they posted and people
are just roasting it after all the time
they spent creating it
heart and soul but here's the thing
that's the world we live in I mean right
yeah yeah people were not gonna let it
go because people thought it right and
then they jumped on it
yeah that's just tough that's fun yeah I
wanted to share that
yeah that's funny that's very funny
I know what I think it is I know it it's
an Embrace when I know well and that I
enjoy that
it's about the Potter
oh boy all right we got some good jokes
coming in here on the joke feedback hour
um
gosh 20 people thank y'all for hanging
out
when we start promoting this thing it's
game over game over
it's like when we have people on the
like about having people on the show
we're like when we when we yeah but
until then we just gonna keep on keeping
them keep on keeping on hey you know
what we should do we should get Adam on
the pot we definitely speaking of which
all right
Adam Adam has to be our first guest
he has to be
and he's endured so much
um
all right
so
oh oh Yoshi screen went blank for a
second he's back
Victoria said welcome back Yoshi
yeah
I'm recovered I went to therapy after
that loss I was like hey
um
how do you get over getting your soul
sucked out of your body
and spending a lot of money
I was rooting for y'all so tough too
like I really wanted to see y'all win I
really did
so many people were rooting for us
yeah no I mean let them down it is what
it is I mean I
just oh
here's I do I do have a joke about this
of how
black and white people treated that loss
very differently like all the white
people that I saw like were like oh
they're like that's so sad I'm so sorry
for you guys it's very sympathetic very
very sympathetic I got on the MARTA to
leave when I got back in town and I had
my TCU good on bruh this black dude
he went he was already on the bus but he
saw me came out of the train I was like
man y'all got y'all asses
I didn't show up for that game I was
like I did not need this right now
so bad was it the worst ever he went in
he went in and then as soon as I sat
down somebody else came on just looked
at me was like damn
y'all got y'all asses kit
bye for still wearing it though
what'd you say mad props for still
wearing it I was represented I was still
represent because you're like wearing a
hospital gown at that part at that point
it was just like Dead Man Walking
yeah
yeah it was a lot of it was a lot of uh
um what's that phrase oh bless your
heart looks oh bless your heart
[Laughter]
there's a lot of that when I when I
arrived back in the city
no
all right well
all right we got some good jokes coming
in and uh we do have a question from
uh Eric Ritter here
who says when you perform in an open mic
that is 95 other Comics that have
decided they are not going to react to
anything
what's the best healthiest mindset to
have
so
I always say the reason for an open mic
even if you're around comics
it's for you
it's for you to feel what the joke
sounds like coming out of your body on a
stage
it's not just the joke itself it's how
you move it's like what you do with like
the pauses that's what the joke is for
and yes it hurts because there's times
when you're not going to get a reaction
from a whole bunch of comedians because
they're just kind of thinking about
themselves doing what they want to do
anyway so I always say it's just more
about what you want to get out of that
night
and out of that open link do you want to
work on these minutes
um I think the hardest part is if
there's real people I say real people
civilians and not Comics
um then I think you just performed to
civilians when possible if it's just
comics
you're just really just working through
your joke
yeah and it's important to remember
every comic does these shows I mean
every single comic your favorite comic
drudged through these shows for years so
just know it's not just you feeling this
way or it's whatever like every comic
must go through this must so just know
that you're not alone and feeling this
or sitting at an open mic and you're
number 25 on the list and you have to be
up at work at seven the next day like
and you're doing three minutes like
everyone goes through this just so you
know and just in terms of Performing
yeah
this is your time you're out treat it do
the set for yourself not for the other
comics in their texting or whatever
and really the more seriously you can
take these sets then the easier good
shows are gonna be because you can treat
this show as if it is a sold out
audience so when you get in front of a
sold out audience it's like you're it's
just mental it's like muscle memory at
that point because you've worked through
it now
it took me a long time to stop bailing
in the middle of a joke or turning
around and rubbing the walls when my
first line doesn't get a laugh
or to roast people in the room because
of my bad material like
it took me a long time to break those
bad habits but
the longer and more mindful you can be
around setting an intention for that set
and just performing for yourself
all of that will add up incrementally
but it's all it's all one set at a time
baby
good mindset though like Yoshi said yeah
do it for do it for yourself I think
that's the best and healthiest mindset
no matter what happens
please listen to your sets after you do
them whatever you do listen to your sets
after you do them even if it was
terrible just get through the mental
pain of listening to yourself and
listening to your set
promise you you will get so much out of
it if you're just recording and you
haven't listened to it
there was no point you gotta listen to
it you got to know like what you did
because in the moment you may have
forgot so yeah just make sure you watch
and listen to yourselves
yep amen and you don't have to post
those sets
by the way you don't have
to post every Open Mic riff you have
I saw a hilarious
um a hilarious photo I did a screenshot
I don't know if it was on here or on my
on my phone
uh it was at an open mic in New York and
someone had like a red Cam set up
four thousand dollars set up and it was
like filming I didn't open my
it was
hilarious dude
how Canadian has this bit about doing
crowd work
have you seen it where he's like hey the
algorithm likes crowd work so I'm gonna
just do it real quick uh what's your
name oh Bob I knew that
artwork over
he goes I just did that one for
algorithms
actually you know what he did and then
he did uh oh my God that's hilarious and
then he uh I'm gonna change the
algorithm up how about you ask me a
question oh what do I do for a living
I'm a comedian this is what I do
I love that
oh it was so silly and just hilarious
dude
so so fun
oh and Alvarez said I always listen to
my sets on the way home
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what I if
yeah while I'm crying it's the best time
to listen to it you know I mean like
just those two emotions go well together
crying about how bad it was
let's put that together yeah yeah and I
realized that if I don't
and I lost all of them no I was gonna
say
I try my best to listen to every single
one but I'm not perfect you know but I
did learn that if I don't listen on the
way home then I'm not gonna listen to it
like I learned that I could romanticize
listening to it in the morning or later
or whatever like if I don't do it on the
way home I'm not gonna do it so I just
had to force myself to do it
so
whatever works for you you do you boo
but yeah I consider reviewing writing
you find new ideas all the time when you
listen to your sets
oh and Eric said very helpful
love ya
[Applause]
all right good question there too Eric
because that's something everybody goes
through
big facts
all right
so
um let's get to some jokes here
um since this is the joke feedback hour
um where are we
oh it's Akuma is here we we deep in here
shot we had 25 people yo and
we don't even promote this that should
be the title of this show we don't
promote
the show
we don't promote the the unpromoted show
I hope that
we're we're gonna we're gonna get better
at it
yeah after that podcast we do with Adam
that's good that's gonna spark it
that's I mean that's that's really going
to be
Next Level you know what I mean yeah
that's how we know
and you know next Tuesday next week I'm
turning 35. so maybe that would be a
good time to bring on Adam
it's my birthday next Tuesday
is it it's the birthday birthday it's
like the day day the day day
yeah I'm white I don't I don't do a
whole week of birthday
you know we do the birthday
you know
I've been to enough comedy shows
where it's like it's my birthday two
weeks ago but we getting lit girl
I love it
oh my gosh oh dude
all right
so
I'm just gonna let my ADD run for a
minute because we were talking about
open mics
I want people to see
I just I just want people to see this
because I was scrolling through like my
Facebook photos
and I found I found a doozy
and just this birthday made me that
birthday
joke reminded me of this show I did I
used to do all the time
and I found a picture of it on my
Facebook and it's called the pizza bar
so it's already off to a good start
that it's a bar of pizza
they had a projector on the wall
of a football game going on
that they didn't shut off during the
comedy show
they they were like no we got to keep
this on
there's hookah
there's no stage
there's no spotlight
there's no f
uck yourself really the perfect setup
for a comedy show
foreign
and this was this was early early in my
career so I'm having to scroll like all
the way to the bottom of my Facebook
but I think it'll be worth it as people
were talking and complaining about open
mics
but mics when no one pays attention
I forgot how far down this was
laughs
dang it that really killed the momentum
but it was hosted by a guy inappropriate
if that helps
Mr inappropriate Mr inappropriate was
his stage name so already right on brand
with me
and my style of Comedy
oh my gosh there's
oops
all right well forget it
oh there it is okay this will be worth
it everyone
I hope
so here it is
see if we can zoom in a little bit so I
mean you can see the crowd is really
into it
I mean if you just look at all the
people paying attention
there's one guy my guy in the Hat he's
into it in the green he's like oh this
this white boy funny the dude right next
to him is looking at look I mean there's
a there's an actual football game on an
entire wall
hahaha
and then she's paying attention she's
more concerned she's like where is his
mother right now
past his curfew
and then here I am in my my Goodwill's
finest I mean you know we really just
yeah and for anyone curious here's the
green room over here there's the Green
Room
you know the comics are really into it
um laughs
and that's just light work you know
that's that's a that's an everyday a day
type of situation
dude these shows every single week fam
uh but yeah I came across that one and
was just like oh I had suppressed that
memory
those are the best
[Laughter]
oh
all right that was worth it for me
yep that trauma yep that's how you know
it's good when it brings up that kind of
like just utter utter instinctual like
oh like you almost like Shake Yourself
I need like the Men in Black zapper
thing to just clear my memory it's like
oh my gosh
all right but anyway
all right let's get to some joke
feedback
um
because that is the name of the show
what do you what do you think Yoshi
should we do some joke feedback let's do
it
all right
um
the timer
it is time for the timer
time for the time it's time for the time
or later it's time for the time of later
Gary said the open mic did they play
Sesame Street
one of these things is not like the
others oh that's hilarious I thought it
was like a street joke but yeah
they probably played Vanilla Ice or
something whack
that's so funny that I yeah
when I would go up there or they'd be
like yo this next comic we came up in
the hood together this is my cousin all
that and then I walk up there
and then I started roasting the hosts
when I they would do that and then they
stopped doing it
[Laughter]
they would do um
it was just they would just kill all
surprises like they would be laughing
when I went up there but it's not my
laugh it's the host laugh and they're
laughing at me it's not like they're not
laughing at my material they're like oh
he's because White and the host said
that thing that wasn't really the thing
you know it was like it just set the set
off on the wrong foot
yeah yeah now you gotta dig yourself out
and establish yourself yeah I mean I
could ride the wave but that's that's
lazy and that's whack so yeah I never
want to do like pandering stuff
um
all right oh Alvaro said the episodes
are very helpful well thank you that's
the whole goal fam
ah zaynova what's up
all right let's do some joke feedback
as I let's we should get a counter for
how many times I say it before we
actually do it
that's what we need to do all right
let's get some joke feedback then 20
minutes later it's just let's get some
joke feedback going that is the name of
the show and then I wonder why we go
till 6 30.
Mike you should really tighten this
thing up and then it's 6 30 we're like
we gotta go guys sorry
all right we got a timer we're gonna run
through these
um
first one or the second one we read
Phil's
um
[Music]
it looks like moodit
mudit Verma
here we go my Hindu parents forced me to
be vegetarian but there's one exception
to my diet animal crackers
they're Caucasians pretending to be
animals AKA furries
foreign
I feel like it would be funnier if they
forced him to be vegan but then the
exception was animal crackers
because then it's more like you don't
eat anything animal but
I guess vegetarian is I don't know I
feel like vegan would be more closely
tied to animal
s
um
do you know what a vegetarian and the
vegan is
what's the I mean vegetarian eats
vegetables but they vegetarian would eat
I can't wait for the rest of this
[Laughter]
and that's our time
I'm sorry
a great joke review there
[Laughter]
vegetarians you know they eat vegetables
you know they eat vegetables you know
[Laughter]
oh hilarious
but anyway
your definition of vegetarian it's
vegetarian
what's a vegan
yeah they they don't eat any animal
products
okay what's the difference between
vegetarian and vegan then
vegetarian wool vegetarians like we'll
eat an egg
oh that's right okay yeah a vegan would
not or would not yeah look but a vegan
or not
yeah so that's why I thought vegan is
like no animal stuff so I feel like it's
it's a it's a better and it's more
popular word
yeah that part I can get it's simpler to
say vegans than vegetarian
um so for that part I think you could
probably do that uh but I think
um
the Caucasians pretending to be animals
I think that's just funny I'm not sure I
needed the AKA Ferries
at the end
um
but I'm trying to think why it's not
I think it's just probably too many
words
yeah I don't get the they're caucasians
pretending to be animals or AKA furries
I don't really get those
I think just change it to vegan and then
leave it there
yeah
mainly because I think I was thinking
animal crackers
uh well I think it's the cracker part
icular cracker you just I just want to
say cracker
that's all that was
that's just funny because you're like I
don't get the Caucasian part
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm so much for a timer
um
we'll get them next time kids
I hope that helped Moody
yeah yeah all right all right all right
let's let's let's let's let's keep it
moving here
um
let's get to some joke feedback
what's happening
this one is from oh this is from Aaron
all alridge Arledge he posted this on
our Facebook group
ah
you would think Dr bunny hunter would
have made more money during the paper
shortage he's a quicker picker upper
[Music]
I I mean that's a silly joke it's a
silly joke Bounty Paper quicker picture
upper
I got it
I think that instead of you would think
Dog the Bounty Hunter would have made
more money I think just saying
yeah say he like he he got rich
um during the paper shortage he's the
quicker picker upper or something like
that like instead of you would think
that just make that thing the reality
and it makes it a little more immediate
it raises the stakes
and it's just more fun to imagine oh
that did happen as opposed to imagining
that it didn't happen
yeah
yep that's it I'll put it in a present
active mode and just start Dog the
Bounty Hunter made a lot of money
yeah yeah
I mean I can't say that's gonna work on
stage
but
I get the I get the word it's it's a
silly goosery joke it's silly goose
there
silly goose for sure
um
Rector Nation
uh dungeons do you know them no oh I
said um like you guys know each other
like no rector's here I see erector
um
all right uh Dungeons and Dragons is
like BDSM people wear costumes there's a
lot of role play and it takes place in
my parents basement
people wear costumes yeah
foreign
I mean yeah
I see the power of Threes there's an
analogy
oh I would use last words like
people wear costumes do role play
and takes place in my parents basement
like that's the only thing I would say
but outside of that I mean I think
that's just one of those you got to try
on stage and see if you need all those
Works to get there
yep and even like it takes place in my
parents basement like you want the
punchline to be as quick as possible so
it could be it happens
in my parents basement so it's like any
word you can get rid of can help the
joke to land harder
yeah
I see the joke there
cool
thanks for sharing
uh
memory memory
uh hickeys are a great proof that your
partner is not a vampire or one with a
lot of self-control
oh my heavenly day
a great proof that your partner is not a
vampire
okay it just it's like it's a phrase
it's not it didn't really come up as a
joke to me
yeah there's not a
surprise
it's not a big enough surprise or a big
enough
left turn here
anyway so it could I mean this is just
left field it's like um
I dated a vampire with self-control so
they gave me hickeys
um like just something
that kind of is a little more jokey
structurey
but there's also not memory in here so
it's like what are how can you
personalize this joke how can you really
put yourself in it somehow
yeah
now if your ex was a vampire now that
would be funny oh okay yeah make it your
ex yeah something like that yeah yeah
but it's a funny idea
so you're on the right track there
all right
uh next joke
next joke next joke
I think Joe kehotek
this one's yours right
after watching UCLA beat Kansas to get
to Sweet 16 there was a dead bird on the
sidewalk someone said I think that's a
Jayhawk
so Kansas
their mascot is The Jayhawks
but
this is us this is like a
this is like a street joke right like
it's just like something that you say
amongst friends and it's like oh that's
funny
the bird on the side of the road is a
Jayhawk
but on a stage
it just doesn't hit
it just wouldn't hit even if everyone
knew UCLA they know Kansas they know
basketball they know sweet 16. yeah
it's just not that much of a surprise
it's also like you had to be there
yeah kind of like this time this one
time at this one place there was this
very specific thing that happened to
this very specific group of people
yeah
I mean right it's like
but I mean that's so that's how to say I
mean that's that's a funny situation to
happen I could see that being funny
in the moment but like for it to
translate to stage
I just don't I don't think so
yeah you go with that
yep I am
all right cool
let's leave that one on the sidewalk
yeah
oh Joe said that's not a joke just a
comment about getting roasted after a
game
well I think that's what we just said
it's not a joke
feedback that is a really good save
though
but you know what in his in his defense
that he may have because that was posted
a while ago you know that may have been
posting We were talking about TCU so
actually in his defense
he may be right
[Laughter]
but now that I think about it
but it also didn't he didn't put joke in
front of it so
that's on me yeah that's on me there
uh we have Victoria
sick burn
Victoria put joke in front of hers so
here we go
like an adult
uh joke I just completed a comedy World
Tour it was so much fun telling jokes in
all different countries at Epcot Center
nice
I like it
I just don't know if it hits hard
because I like obviously the surprises
that you're doing a world tour at the
Epcot Center which is funny
um but I think this is one of those like
I'd want to know more
because you were telling jokes at Disney
I feel like there's other things that
could happen here
I don't know there's something about
if you led with this
you almost have to get to like
different tags on what you saw at Disney
foreign
I think making sure you pause before uh
Epcot Center
so making sure you build up that
misdirect and all the different
countries pause
at Epcot Center
uh I think that would really help
really just make that misdirect land I
mean I don't hate it really
I'd be interested to see if if it works
on stage you just never know
but I don't hate it
no
but the misdirect is there that you may
just need to rework
yeah the details in the setup but I
would maybe try it as is and then see
what sticks
cool
yeah thanks Victoria
um next joke
James
scouten
the porn star awards were last week in
Las Vegas they were everywhere I was in
line at a Starbucks looked over my left
shoulder and there was Jenna Jameson
thank you Vegas for the Memories
[Music]
such a long such a long way
thanked Jenna directly that would be
funny
um but
I mean I don't it's like a silly thing
like I feel like if you did this on
stage they may be like ah
or like oh I see what you did there like
this isn't a joke that's like oh LOL
funny it's more of like oh I see what
you did there memories memories type
deal
but I would say not thank you Vegas
thank her and that'll make it a little
more personal
yeah
thanks man
yeah but it's all right
thanks for sharing there
James
um
Lance Stewart
supposedly Millennials are bad at naming
things especially babies I think doctors
are a lot worse I discovered a new
disease I'll name it after me
if my name ain't doctor
Alois
Alzheimer
alloyus
I don't know if Alloys I don't know if
that's part of it
I think it's just Dr Alzheimer right
that's basically the joke okay
naming things especially babies I think
doctors are a lot worse I discovered a
new disease I'll name it after me
I think my doctor Alzheimer's
little littles are bad at naming things
especially babies
I feel like two different things are
going on
yeah that's a good point yeah
a lot worse
but you could just condense it to um
I heard Millennials are bad at naming
things
uh or you don't have to say name like
just for word economy not bad at naming
things especially babies
Millennials are bad at naming babies
it's just like yeah get to the point
and then in my opinion doctors are a lot
worse
and then Dr Alzheimer
um
foreign
yeah Millennials are bad at naming
babies doctors are worse
I discovered a new disease I name it
after me Dr Alzheimer I think the hard
part even with that is that
are you the doctor
because you just say I'll name it after
me Dr Alzheimer because you're like
talking in third person and then you go
to first person
oh he said there's more context I tried
to beat the character count
um
gotcha that's what we always do I always
try to beat the character beat the
character count the word economy
but yeah right now it's kind of yeah
there's kind of two different things
going on here
um
but just word economy Millennials are
bad at uh naming babies
and then I think it could be like Dr
Alzheimer
is the person like I think there's
there's something going on with like the
doctor's name being bad so like the
millennial name the doctor Dr Alzheimer
or maybe boomers are worse
uh take that Dr Alzheimer or something
like that but
yeah we're trying we're like we're
trying to
resuscitate this one but sometimes you
know
somebody needs to call a doctor on this
joke
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's so good yeah good point
Doctor Is In the House
all right next joke
we have from uh Zeb
Valentine we haven't seen Zeb in a while
good to see Zeb in her
yeah I got my degree online which is
like having a mail order bride it's
expensive people question it's validity
it's not good for anything but it's cute
to have
so I see the analogy
the degree online mail order bride he's
going for a power of threes
it's expensive people question it's
validity and it's not good for anything
but it's cute to have so we need to
tighten up that third like we power of
Threes you know we got this is almost
like a four
not good for anything but cute to have
so we need a more surprising third in
this
which could be
it's expensive people question it's a
little bit validity
and um it's overpriced it won't help you
get a job
um
yeah not that big of a left turn
and just a phrase but it's cute to have
a catfish it feels very
meh in the sense of
in comparison to what a mail order bride
is
um
so just more surprising third
uh
but otherwise I mean there's a power of
Threes there so I think there's
something there in the analogy
yeah so just look at what's true for an
online degree what's true for mail order
bride
and try to pick like a surprising
third
yeah
nice
all right
uh uh keto Carol
this one's you uh running with a
weighted vest is the newest stupid
Fitness fad waste money on an expensive
vest when you could just stay home and
Order ubereats and add weight to your
middle the old-fashioned way
yeah yeah
I like that and that my brain was going
to like
waste money on expensive vests and
somehow like you just gain the weight is
where my brain was going
so I think you could just say that in a
quicker way
then just
new stupid Fitness fad waste money
expensive why waste money on expensive
vests
when you can gain weight the
old-fashioned way
I don't know
so the add week to your middle the
old-fashioned way
is
that's the only part that's done because
I feel like the middle I've never heard
of your body part like in
referred to as the middle
so maybe that's just me
and wait to your middle yeah it would be
like your belly get fat I mean
or it could just be I prefer to
get my weighted vest from ubereats so
then it's kind of like saying
you're gaining weight from ubereats it's
just saying it more efficiently
I hope that helps
let's hope so let's hope so I hope that
helps
um
say what
so we deep in here we go oh my gosh 30
live and we don't even promote this this
is great oh we just dropped to 23. as
soon as you see
foreign
literally as soon as you said it seven
people disappeared
the Russian Bots were like yeah we're
out of here
it's hilarious oh Carol said I could say
I saw one at Dick's Sporting Goods I
prefer to get mine from ubereats
yeah yeah I like that
um
Tracy J
five o'clock traffic is insane everybody
everyone just decides to drive around
for hours and road rage at the same time
every day like
like I wonder if everyone is coming
tomorrow
I don't know where
there's no like
what up
where the joke is yeah there's no like
misdirect here there's no what would be
called a punchline
I think it's the question of is everyone
coming tomorrow
I think that's where the
haha is
um right
so maybe there's something with a
traffic phrase you could do like
gridlock
traffic jam
bumper to bumper
road rage
five o'clock Travis design everyone
decides to drive around for hours
and road rage at the same time every day
yeah I feel like that's another there's
too many things happening I think five
o'clock traffic is insane
everyone has a road rage at the same
exact time and then they all decide
let's do this tomorrow
yeah yeah same time tomorrow yeah yes
tomorrow yeah yeah but I like feel like
that I wonder if everyone is coming
tomorrow it just feels too long and too
yeah I like that yeah same time tomorrow
I think that's yeah that could work
mm-hmm
good save
um
Bobby
being sick has revealed talents I never
knew I had anyone else ever belch barf
pee and shart yourself with just one
sneeze
just me why is it always me
foreign
so I like all of the joke except like
just the just me and it always just me
mainly because I feel like we're
learning a lot about you being sick and
you have talents
I when you put the barf belch pee and
shark out there
I think I was just wondering like what
do you call it
right like it's almost like give it a
name
uh
and also like rephrase it to
be in a more of an active voice I like
has revealed talents I never knew I now
know how to belch barf p and shot myself
with one cease
I call it uh or whatever yeah and it
could be like like a grand slam since
there's four of them it could be some
sort of grand slam
deaths
that's funny yeah yeah
there's something Grand Slam
yeah or um
something like that run or yeah
the the butts or
The Heirs you know I'm saying something
that like
huh yeah there's something there but I
think
just the just me
feels much more
I mean I think you could say it but it
feels more like a filler rather than a
punchline
yeah yeah I don't think yeah I don't
think it ended joke on a question I
think it is like as I call it the blank
Grand Slam or as my doctor called it
this I don't or it could just be the
Grand Slam I don't know
um a grand slam
yeah or or you can surprise yourself or
as I call it a normal Tuesday
yeah there's a missed Rick there yeah
yeah
but I mean there's that's yeah that's
very personal there that is
oh my heavens we need a fart sound
effect
that's when we know we've really got
high brow when it's there's our fart
sound effect
let's go take us next level that's next
level next week
and then fart sounds
he's coming in for a special surprise
[Laughter]
all right
uh looks like we just got a few more
here uh
zaynova
this is for mine yeah
um
my lady wants to fly private on our next
vacation
I told her that's fine
just don't tell anyone and it's done
[Music]
that's hilarious
that's so silly that is so silly
uh my lady wants to fly private on our
next vacation
I told her that's fine just don't tell
anyone and it's done I feel like the
punch line could be
um I don't know like I won't tell if you
don't tell oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I won't tell if you won't
yeah that's really funny I like I like
that edit though I won't tell if you
want
but that is whole that is funny
education I told her I won't tell if you
don't it's like can you keep a secret
um
gossip I don't know I won't tell if you
don't I like that
that's funny nice job there zainova very
nice
um
Tavis Aikman
people talk about catching coven now
like they're playing Modern clue who did
it it was Joel at the hospital without a
mask
now like they're playing Modern clue who
did it
is usually better than this
um
I think he just wanted to hear his name
red on the air on this one I don't I
don't think he means it I don't think he
meant this one
people talk about catching Cove and like
they're playing Modern clue
who did it
Joel osmo without a mask
so
I I actually think the who did it part
is funny Joel but I think you have to
then do like the questions that Clues
ask you where was it done and what the
circumstance was or else you don't get
that it's like modern clue right so it's
like I think there's three things that
happens like it's who did it
what were they wearing and where did it
happen kind of thing
that's true yeah if you're gonna bring
up an analogy you need to bring up
true things from that example you're
using
yeah and I think what would actually
make this funny
is uh if you did the other question and
then the last one is who did it it was
me I caught it like that's a better
surprise
than someone else who's not like in the
joke
nice
yeah thanks for sharing there Tavis
sorry to roast you there
we appreciate you being here like every
week
oh stay
um
all right looks like
it's sad that we like Tavis literally
comes every single
I know
oh you can do better
it comes from
it comes from the heart but also that's
like that's a great thing because that's
us setting expectations based on your
joke writing we're like oh damn like
that means like you're making an impact
that we're like oh
oh Tavis come on now we can
we've seen like you do stuff that's much
better than this so yeah I think it's
it's a good thing
even though we're roasting you and just
remember we're coming
we're we kind of I think you have to
roast I think that's part of the comedy
that's part of the NDA when you become a
comedian before you say I'm a comedian
you must be okay with getting roasted at
any moment anytime
Mig facts not by your parents but if
that happens then that also happens
or your life
or your kids like Daddy you're not that
funny
I could have told him that I don't know
I didn't know it was up to debate
[Laughter]
um
Elaine
Elaine Myleene Milan I hope I'm saying
that right
is this mine or yours is this mine
um this is yours yeah the kid at the
beginning of Jurassic Park who claims a
velociraptor looks more like a six foot
turkey
as if a six foot turkey isn't something
mortally fear
I'm afraid of a regular sized turkey
um
you know what's funny I said that um I
didn't know whether it was a sound
effect or whether that came out of your
mouth
maybe
that should be a sound effect because we
don't get just um
[Laughter]
claims
we gotta ask Adam just to do our sound
effects on the next podcast
can I come on the show first I mean
goodness
um
kids beginning of Jurassic Park who
claims Velociraptor looks more like six
foot turkey has a six foot turkey so in
the morning Pierre
uh some too mortally Fair
I'm afraid of a regular sized turkey
okay
I think it's just wordy
it's really the thing that throws me off
because the kid at the beginning of
Jurassic Parks who claims
uh
I don't know I feel like we just have to
put in context
in Jurassic Park I could claims a
velociraptor looks like a six foot
turkey
as if a six foot turkey isn't
something to mortally fear
I'm afraid of a regular size Junkie
so we almost I think we don't know how
she feels
about it in it so if it's something like
um
Jurassic Park
is SK is um
is it it exaggerates Jurassic Park is
unrealistic
they claim a velociraptor
is a scary six foot turkey
I'm afraid of a regular-sized turkey
so something's setting up how Jurassic
Park is
it's unrealistic it's fake it's not
um
foreign there needs to be like an
opinion in it
to then have the misdirect of like I'm
afraid of a regular-sized turkey
yeah but honestly if you're afraid of
regular sized turkey
I feel like there could be like a
Thanksgiving joke
um
it's just such a specific reference
yeah and then there's a Thanksgiving
joke there but like you almost have to
not make it about the turkey because
you've already mentioned the turkey so
like it's almost like
I'm afraid around stuffing or uh
you know I don't know there's something
like six foot turkey and then your
punchline being a regular sized turkey
just isn't a big enough of a surprise or
a big enough of a left turn or
um maybe a regular sized turkey it's I'm
afraid of a Thanksgiving turkey
um yeah because like that's a quicker
punch line it's a little more
descriptive yeah and it's still saying a
normal turkey but in a funnier way
and then my mind also went to I'm also
afraid of the country Turkey you can
also do that
uh
trying to think what else bowling turkey
yeah when you get like three in a row I
think yeah
I think I'm just that's what's missing
there's no emotion
of this in this of how you feel about it
although like the fact that you're like
oh this is mortally fearful
um
it's just Jurassic Park is such it's
such a specific reference
like that's like you have to almost know
the movie and that they say this in the
movie like is there another example of a
turkey
that you could still get the point
across that you're afraid of like a
Thanksgiving turkey
yeah
I don't know what that is
yeah we might need a doctor on this joke
too
but you being afraid of a regular sized
turkey is funny and I'd love to hear
more about that
that's very interesting
and maybe more of your fears or
something like that
um
but thanks for sharing
we gave that one a go
we did
um
all right I think we're coming down to
the last few here
all right
Jerry Kroll
I held back on cussing in front of my
kids and so they were 10. my wife
apparently wanted our boys to be cool
cussing kids in the preschool
the cool cussing kids
um
and he said he will cut out the until
they were 10 part
yeah
so basically the premise is
um that
he's raising his kids one way his wife
is raising them another
so it could be like he raised his kids
to use their words
his wife made sure those were swear
words
um
we have different parenting styles
I avoid cussing in front of my kids
while my wife cusses at them
um
I just think I wanted our boys to be the
cool custom kids in preschool is like
I think he's basically trying to say
my wife cusses in front of the kids so
it's like I think there's a more
efficient way to say wanted our boys to
be the cool cussing kids in preschool
yeah and also just using cussing again
just doesn't resonate I feel like you
just gotta cuss like
wanted our boys to be the cool
[__] kids in preschool or
something like just
okay
that's what's happening here is that you
don't curse in front of him but your
wife apparently does so I almost feel
like say something cool that she'd want
them to say in preschool like on their
first day so when or like on their first
day it was like where's my [__]
books you know what I'm saying look
there's something that would show that
she won or that she her
like her way got the way in some way
that's the only thing that threw it off
I feel like cussing in front of the kids
and then the cool cussing kids in
preschool
it's kind of a mouthful
so I feel like you can just shorten it
just by cussing
it's true
but if he doesn't want to cuss
yeah I like the premise I just
so maybe it's a little yeah maybe just
like the
Maybe the cool kids in school like maybe
just like make a sound or just a cool
you mean like that's
I don't know there's something about it
but saying custom
again just feels like it throws it off
for me
cool
I hope that helps there Jerry
yeah
um Jerry's sitting at home like all
right right
hello
um
all right maybe two more here
oh and Alvaro asked if his got
uh it did get held for review
there Alvaro his joke is my dream has
always been to be on Conan and by that I
mean I want to be f'd by a barbarian
all right
she really enjoyed that one
well there you go there Alvaro
[Laughter]
I mean it's a solid joke structure and
it's a nice misdirect I enjoyed it yeah
I agree
yeah I enjoyed it as well
nice another Alvaro nice nice misdirect
um solid
Brian Smith and this may be the last one
here
sent you
my my mom taught me how to drive when I
was 11 years old
uh-oh is there something in the joke I
didn't get that far what do you laugh
okay
the Yoshi the Edibles kicking in for
Yoshi so we gotta get out of here before
he passes out and we get demonetized
[Laughter]
um
sorry go ahead go ahead that's on me no
you're good my mom taught me how to
drive when I was 11 years old
still till this day I don't know if she
wanted to teach me how to drive or if it
was just because the car was stolen and
she was high
I like the premise of this I think it's
very funny
um
I actually wanted to teach me how to
drive
I think so I like the premise basically
being around
um
the premise being around basically he
had a like his bad mother he had a bad
mother so I think another misdirect
could be
that or if she was just too drunk to
drive
so it's saying the same thing but just a
little more quickly you know
I don't know if she wanted to teach me
how to drive or if she was just too
drunk to drive
yeah
yeah the stolen part really doesn't help
the joke just I like the thought that
she was high
um
yeah we're too drunk to drive I think
that works
yeah I think drunk actually works better
because it's drunk is much more
associated with driving than being high
is
yeah you could say you could try too
high to drive or too drunk to drive
either one may work but either way the
whole point is that the premises my mom
was a bad mom so how can I say this
and that's just a quicker way to say it
then or if it was just because the car
was stolen and she was high
just make it like a single quicker
snappier phrase
nice
um yeah uh somebody just asked can high
be attacked yeah I think the high part
can definitely be attacked that's smart
six tags
yeah something about like getting pulled
over according to the cops
or according to the police she was drunk
or too drunk to drive
and the cops want to ask me if I reached
puberty yet or something like that yeah
just a scenario that pulled over this is
funny yeah it could that could be a tag
though or it's like or if she was too
drunk to drive or according to the or
that's at least what the police report
said
or if you get pulled over the cops get
him out and says you have to be this
High to ride this ride
oh yeah yeah yeah because he's a little
kid he's like 11 yeah
well actually she is that high
had to be this High to drive
it's like oh I guess Mom you can take
over now
nicely done though
nicer nice one to end on there Brian
Doug B Smith
all right shall we land This Plane
Pamela says hey hey Pamela
uh Aaron asked for doing mics tonight
uh I'm recording a YouTube video tonight
that's where I'm at
I'm recording a YouTube video about Nate
bargatzi
coming up next
before his special comes out on um
he's got a special coming out on January
31st
so I'm recording it tonight
so I won't be doing an open mic tonight
but
um I'm hosting a show this Saturday and
Tucker
which does um I wonder does Aaron live
in Atlanta is he in Athens
I don't know where he was
he's in Athens
thanks
I don't I don't know how funny he is or
not maybe he could do the show Saturday
I don't know how funny he is or not
oh
maybe I don't know
based on this joke feedback
oh Loganville
oh that's just right down the street son
should he pull up
Aaron how long
how long you been doing comedy here
Bobby said she's headlining in Georgia
on the 20th
where's she gonna be where are you gonna
be about where is that
oh he's been doing it seven months
give him a little time
thank God
pull up Aaron pull up you got time pull
up pull up
give him five
yeah
hot five a hot five maybe a type three
we'll see how it goes we'll see if he
gets the checkpoint best best way to say
it
it's just though the light comes up as
soon as you start dying
type five a hot three yes or a hot five
tight three a hot five that's hilarious
it'll be um
it's high card brewing and Tucker
Aaron send us a send us a message send
me a message on Facebook or uh Instagram
I'll share the Deets and villarica
Bobby's gonna be in Villa Rica
nice Bobby oh I don't know where that is
Villa Rica is down
yeah
nice well congrats there Bobby
that's awesome
boy
well good well let's land This Plane
Aaron got him booked himself a spot way
to go Aaron and Bobby headlining
I love it
awesome
so yeah go
should we land This Plane I mean and
let's land it let's make it do what it
does
all we ask just tell your friends about
the show
oh yeah I do this every Tuesday
every Tuesday
when
my school who hasn't been in the
championship
uh it's obliterated and I need an
emotional support animal
uh to make sure that I'm okay amen now
amen yeah I'm glad you bounced back
and Pamela said she just produced her
own show and it was a success very nice
well it does that's awesome
your classes and advice are the best oh
thank you
thank you Pamela
hey
so yeah tell your friends we're here
every single Tuesday let's keep
spreading the hopper at the verse
word
and uh we outcha
you ready Yoshi
let's do it
we love y'all we'll see y'all next week
bye
[Music]
are we off
I forgot to say angels on y'all
yeah Angel's on y'all we'll see y'all
next week bye y'all